hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
today we're talking with Glen Morton
he's the author of the new book passing
Obamacare and he's got almost two
decades in the insurance business he's
worked for providers insurers and as an
insurance broker Glen thanks for talking
to us thank you appreciate okay first
off tell us what's a health insurance
broker do what what you know how do you
how do you make a buck well in the
health insurance marketplace health
insurance brokers we were the hunters
you know we seek out bad insurance
purchases and we make them better you
know that's that's how we eat so you
mostly go to say like a business because
most insurance is delivered through an
employer and you say okay look you've
got a hundred employees and this is this
is kind of the distribution of them
you're paying too much for this coverage
you could get a better deal here you
could actually you're probably under
ensuring people in this way so build
that up well that's that's one example
of it one of the things that you'll
realize when you get more involved in
insurance is that you can look at to
benefit summary side by side and you
know the average person can tell which
one was better than the other and
couldn't tell how each benefit
reimburses a provider you know for
service the only thing they know is
what's my share what you know what do I
pay right so what are the guidelines
about in President Obama's health care
reform obama care at what's is there a
role left for brokers or does that all
go away no no it completely eliminated
the health insurance broker marketplace
okay and how did it do that there was a
report that came out recently from
McKinsey & Company and it said that four
people had a good understanding of the
law half of them would drop
employer-sponsored coverage and put
their employees in the exchange and it
was a lot of pushback from the
administration because the Congressional
Budget Office had said that you know
seven percent of eligible people would
get in the exchange and these are the
government structured health care
exchanges where people
go and shop for guaranteed health yeah
it's like yeah I mean you know they
designed Obamacare in the exchanges to
be better than the employer-based market
so for anyone even the Congressional
Budget Office to estimate that only
seven percent of people would realize
that I mean it's just kind of
disingenuous the contribution that the
federal government makes is based on the
ability of the individual to afford the
coverage not the ability of the employer
to contribute to it and Obamacare is set
up so that if the federal government
needs more money to fund that high level
of contribution it can take it from any
more you know even people that have not
purchased health insurance no employer
can can duplicate that level of
contribution ultimately everybody is
going to go into the exchange so what is
it a bad thing if everybody goes into
the exchanges or why is that a bad thing
well it's a bad thing because we can't
afford it I mean frankly if if there was
an estimate done by the Congressional
Budget Office it said seven percent of
people who are eligible to get into the
exchange that translates to about 9 and
10 million people they said the cost of
that would be 2.5 trillion dollars if
the mckinsey report McKinsey survey
rather which records people's opinions
not some statistical model right said
that half of the people have a good
understanding would get in the exchange
that means 78 million people would be in
exchange so if 10 million people cost
2.5 trillion dollars imagine what 78
million people would cost and this is
just 2011 the percentage of people that
are going to have a good understanding
of the exchange by 2014 is going to be
much higher than it and that's when they
actually things totally shift over
that's what 2014 is when our country
changes substantially glen morton author
of passing obamacare and a health
insurance heavyweight thank you very
much for talking to reason TV thank you
for reason TV i'm nick gillespie